We are present in 140 countries, so it's very important to have talent from different cultures...
...and it's such a cosmopolitan place that you can attract...
...retained talent from anywhere in the world.
Out of 18 people who report directly to me, we have 10 different nationalities.
People are very tolerant, very open to difference...
...and I think it's a great attribute.
Here I am, a Frenchman working for an American company,...
...leading an international division based in the UK.
I don't think this would happen easily anywhere else, frankly.
Not only do I like working, but I love living in Britain.
Well apart from the fact that for whatever reason...
...that nobody in the rest of the world understands,...
...you guys are driving on the wrong side of the road,...
...I would say it's very pleasant to drive in the UK.
I think British drivers are careful, are very respectful, polite.
You systematically let pedestrians cross the road...
...and one stops, which is in a big city quite amazing to me compared to other big cities.
The rate of accidents is significantly lower in the UK than it is in other countries...
...which says something significant about the character of the British population.
This being said, I wouldn't say that British people are slaves to the rules;...
...actually, they are very creative.
I think British people can get crazy.
This creativity mixed with the solid structure of tolerance and respect...
...is actually a very good product in the end.
That's what makes it really enjoyable and a unique place.